vous ne me connaissez pas imaginez-vous
de hambach je vous bouscule
ai-je vraiment trop bien oui
probablement avec du thé vert genevois
que la moitié d'entre vous est double
hélas je vais vous décevoir je dois vous
avouer quelque chose j'ai ton handicap
oui je suis en 10 capes est nul
incapable enfant j'avais un plan je me
voyais terminer mes études bien gagner
ma vie me marier avoir des enfants
à l'époque tout allait bien j'avais des
bonnes notes à l'école je gagnais des
prix aux compétitions d'équitation et en
plus cerise sur le gâteau je plaisais
aux garçons certes je me sentais victime
de la jalousie des autres
l'habile vie que je menais avait une fin
la réalité ton tout effarante ma vie
ressemble à temps suite à des montagnes
russes
un accident de circulation une rupture
sentimentale
une agression et l'accident la chute en
2008 j'étais ton équipe suisse avec les
juniors engraissage jallet de
compétition en compétition
d'entraînement en entraînement lors
d'une séance soudainement mon cheval se
cabra ils s'en vont vers ça sur moi 600
kilos
une demi tonne de muscles et d'os jeu
fut donnée pour morte
telle est la proximité entre la vie et
la mort le jour et la nuit
leur rêve et l'enfer la vie paisible que
je menais alors s'était soudainement
transformé en bête furieuse héliporté à
l'hôpital
je passais au scanner le diagnostic fut
sévère un traumatisme crânien je dû
subir une opération
le chirurgien ôta en morceaux du crâne
et le conte jaune à amou 70 degrés
pendant ce temps là je dormais non pas
comme toutes les nuits j'étais dans le
coma
une situation si tragique car on ne sait
pas quand l'on va s'est réveillé après
trois jours trois semaines trois ans ou
jamais par chance au bout d'un mois
j'ai ouvert un à lille j'ai dit mon
premier mot ce plus une fête la même que
celle d'un enfant qui dit son premier
mot wahou
c'était dans grand moment pour mes
parents
certes la rééducation allait être longue
je ne me suis pas levé de mon lit comme
tous les matins j'ai pris deux mois pour
retrouver la conscience deux mois
pendant lesquels j'étais confuse
totalement confuse
j'étais en colère je criais jeu
houspillait des ordres ou aux
infirmières je frappais quiconque
s'approchait de moi
et finalement ma maman devait négocier
avec moi comme avec des enfants avec des
chocolats
oui mais cela ne durera pas bien
longtemps
je fus déprimé je voulais mourir
rien n'est impossible
je ne pouvais plus rien faire je n'en
valait pas la peine
à ce moment là c'est ma maman kg à créer
le déclic c'est elle qui m'a ramené à la
maison pour un week end seulement un
week end
me retrouver dans mon environnement
familial le cadre que je vivais tous les
jours en passant par une visite chez mon
cher cheval avant de retourner à
l'hôpital était pour moi une révélation
depuis j'ai retrouvé la conscience mais
surtout la motivation la semaine
suivante je fus jeu toutes les thérapies
bref je voulais avancer
à ce moment là j'avais compris ce que
signifiait la neuroplasticité c'est la
capacité du cerveau à créer une nouvelle
connexion
dès ce moment pour moi cela voulait dire
que tout est possible
oui tout
pour revenir à la vie réapprendre les
gestes les plus simples que l'on fait au
quotidien tenir une fourchette aller aux
toilettes ou encore cuisiner en neuf
je devais tout réapprendre un chemin
long et difficile
ils allaient parfois être pénible mais
je voulais avancer
comment ailleurs church in a dit un
pessimiste voit la difficulté dans
l'opportunité un optimiste voit
l'opportunité dans la difficulté qu'on
est utiles avec le cheval bien sûr
j'aurais pu le détester il était la
source de mes ennuis mais c'était aussi
un très bon thérapeute un très bon
médecin psychologue mais surtout mon
meilleur ami je lui parlais je lui donne
à manger des bisous le carré ce jeu lui
confier tous mes secrets
telle fut la proximité de ma relation
captivante avec mon cheval
en 2010 j'ai pu reprendre la compétition
à haut niveau
non pas avec les valides
mais en ce temps handicap je voulais
inspirer d'autres personnes d'autres
personnes dans la même situation que moi
que l'on pouvait continuer sa vie
continue et reprendre ses activités
j'ai participé à deux compétitions et je
fus qualifié pour la première fois pour
les jeux équestres mondiaux
il était auquel tous qui les états unis
il fallait traverser l'océan
oui tout est possible j'ai remporté les
4e rang par la suite je veux je
réalisais que je vais parcouru un chemin
difficile que je venais de loin je
voulais aider d'autres personnes
alors pour vous j'ai publié mon
autobiographie
pas sympa oui
pas à pas je voyais dès le départ un
long tunnel noir est sombre et au bout
il y avait une petite lumière claire et
brillante et là c'était mon objectif
là où je voulais aller chaque progrès
chaque pas en avant et est pour moi une
victoire pour aller encore beaucoup plus
loin
certes les défis ce ne furent pas
terminé il fut marquée par le divorce de
mes parents
cela signifiait la rupture avec papa ou
plutôt sa rupture avec moi c'était
terrible difficile inacceptable pourtant
j'ai dû avancer je me retrouvais sans
formation je ne gagne pas d'argent et
j'avais la charge financière dans cheval
instinctivement je vais vite réalisé que
je devais créer ma place gagner de la
visibilité pour espérer un jour avoir du
soutien
en 2012
un ami me proposait de participer à
l'élection de miss handicap
encore un concours de beauté je ne
savais pas quoi faire
certes je découvris que c'était la
chance éventuellement devenir
l'ambassadrice pour les personnes
handicapées dès ce jeudi le jour où je
fus courcouronnes et je m'investis pour
notre égalité et neutre inclusion dans
la société
sensibiliser les personnes aux handicaps
oser s'en approcher ne pas avoir peur
dès ce moment là en parallèle après
avoir beaucoup donné
je tenue je tends du soutien c'était
magnifique
je recevais tout ce que j'avais donnés
c'était pour moi la deuxième chance de
reprendre ma carrière sportive en moins
oui carrière sportive
j'y tenais j'avançais et je m'entraînais
tous les jours sans jamais rien lâcher
je savais qu'elle était mon objectif
et d'autant plus jamais les défis
sportifs surtout professionnel aussi et
personnels jeunes m'ont lancé
ça va permettre d'avancer vous aussi
osez vous défier j'osais me lancer le
défi pour réaliser mon rêve
d'adolescence à 15 ans je rêvais des
jeux olympiques
certes un peu différemment aujourd'hui
on parlera plutôt des jeux paralympiques
le chemin était encore long
je m'étais qualifié à tous les
championnats major les européens les
mondiaux
c'était sur la bonne voie malgré tout la
qualification pour rio-2016 fut
compliqué je devais tout d'abord
qualifier une place pour la suisse c'est
une histoire de quotas au niveau
international une fois celle là si dans
la poche
encore fallait-il restait la meilleure
suissesse afin d'espérer ya 30 jours un
mois
avant notre départ je su que j'étais
qualifié je pouvais m'en volait en
direction du brésil avec le cheval de ma
vie à mon taf être au milieu de ce stade
olympique était pour moi
magique une véritable récompense pour
tous les efforts que j'avais fourni
je m'adresse à vous mesdames messieurs
je vous invite à aimer toutes les
activités que vous exercez avec passion
et conviction être enthousiaste et
positif dans toutes les circonstances et
aborder les défis de la vie avec
confiance en l'avenir
rappelez vous tout est possible
[Applaudissements]